today's new member of the day's Kyle
page Kyle thank you for being a david
pakman show member really appreciate
your support also want to say thank you
to today's longtime sustaining member of
the day Thomas Amin who has been with us
almost five years we actually have a
couple of people who are getting very
close to their nine-year what am i doing
six not in year anniversary I know how
to count fingers trust me nine year
anniversary of membership with the show
isn't that absolutely incredible
we'll be naming some of those people we
will be naming names by the way starting
in April that's when some of their
nine-year anniversaries come up join
them at WWJ pakman.com save 40% if you
want by using the coupon code this is 20
20 and if you want to as I like to say
throw a dollar at us you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and just pledge a
dollar a month it's $12 for the year for
hundreds and hundreds of hours of what I
consider to be pretty okay programming
okay it's time for hatred mail hatred
mail is when a professional voice-over
artist does interpretive readings of the
crazy crazy hatred mail that I get quick
reminder about what we're talking about
when we talk about hatred mail hey let's
face it the only logical response to
guns is more freaking guns
hatred mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom homophobia common in hatred mail
that's part of this week's hatred mail
let's just get right into it you are a
hater of God's Word and a persuasive con
man with false intelligence you mock
that what is good and you will be
severely punished for the filth you spew
bastard
you know what's interesting there's been
a lull in what I guess I would call
religious hatred mail and I don't know
if it correlates with Trump being less
of the sort of evangelical conservative
Republican and as a result the types of
hate mail that I've been getting are
less the type of thing that we would
receive under george w bush's presidency
I don't really know exactly what to make
of it but the religious component of
Patriot mail has been less and less
common being against God's Word and
sinning and going to spend my life an
eternity in hell and all of that other
stuff but sort of refreshing in a way to
get back to the good old fashioned a
sort of Christian hate that we became
accustomed to towards the end of Bush's
presidency and and during Barack Obama's
but I'm not exactly sure what's
responsible for it what I can tell you
is that using the coupon code hatred for
tea will be responsible for many hatreds
crying because their criticisms will
rather than inspire hatred of the show
build financial support for it and if
you go to WWE at muncom the coupon code
hatred for tea will save you 40% off of
the membership of your choice I
encourage you to do it it's like a
middle finger to the hatreds